we've reacted to the topic of vaccines
on middle ground before but now it's
time to react about the question of
whether or not being fat is a choice
it's going to be a worthwhile watch
let's get started being fat or skinny is
a choice this is a very polarizing
question I think it's a false dichotomy
I don't think you have to say it's one
thing or another but their Community
seems to say that it's not a choice so
that's interesting being skinny or being
fat um is about willpower who you choose
to associate with what sort of things
you choose to listen to who you choose
to kind of have as your friends around
you and support you all of those things
are choices that you can make yeah and
you could easily point it in the other
direction and talk about the genetic
components the importance of those who
raised you and how they taught you to
think about food the way that the
frontal lobe developed when you were a
child meaning that if you had higher
exposure to fatty foods growing up or
unhealthy Foods or Ultra processed foods
you may have a pre reference for that
it's not as simple as just this Choice
even with the genetics that caus you to
want to eat more the same solution is
calories and calories out the calories
and calories out thing is true but then
there needs to be a little bit of nuance
here and that Nuance is certain calories
will lead you to metabolize Foods
differently certain calories will lead
you to want to consume more or less of a
certain food and certain calories can be
unhealthy for you for other reasons
other than your weight this is why we're
always against starvation diets or
heavily restrictive diets on this
channel because in many instances they
actually create more problems like
eating disorders disordered eating
unhealthy habits Etc I was supposed to
get blood tested probably when I was
very very young and I never did and they
had mentioned that it could have been
because of my weight and how that
connects with my thyroid and I never had
like that leaning parent to be like go
and get checked out go and do this like
your weight is probably not your fault
it was always like your weight is your
fault so that's your issue that's an
unhealthy mindset if I have a patient
that has not been worked up for a
thyroid condition for other reasons why
someone may be carrying excess weight we
absolutely would check those things if
you have low thyroid hormone we can give
you thyroid hormone to boost those
levels up I mean I also struggle with
you know thyroid and my own blood issues
I'm not quite sure but I do see an
endocrinologist and I go see a doctor
and that's not available to everyone in
the United States especially those who
don't have health insurance or are
underinsured and some people are insured
but don't have adequate Transportation
or they don't have uh paid time off from
work as a disabled woman I can't do a
lot of the things that people say
calories in calories out oh you got to
go work out and exert it I have to
navigate weight differently I have to
look at it differently my weight is the
way it is because of medication because
doctors put me in this position this is
why the false dichotomy pops up in my
head if you're going to be very
stringent and saying being overweight is
a choice fullon you're neglecting a
significant part of the population who
may be having a side effect of a
medication CU there's many medications
that we could put patients on to protect
their health that as a unwanted side
effect they put on weight or they aren
aable to lose weight as easily and then
there's those with disabilities that
can't burn calories as easily as some
who are able-bodied so I think probably
even a better conversation to be had
here is is obesity a disease the AMA and
all the major organizations have made it
a disease process they've labeled it a
disease the doctors who are saying that
that's not helpful are usually pointing
out that when a patient feels obesity
disease they feel powerless to make the
change the way that I like to think
about it is on a population level it's
certainly a disease because it affects
our bodies negatively it's certainly
contributing to a public health epidemic
it's actually happing pandemic really
across the world obesity on an
individual level we need to have
providers who have good relationships
with their patients to make the call is
this something something that I can
present to my patient as a choice that
will get them motivated or is this
something that we can help them navigate
through a medical perspective where we
can give them medications surgeries
maybe lifestyle modifications if they
are going to be motivated to it and make
that call on an individual level but
again all medicine is practiced on
populationbased information and the
research that we have there and then we
as providers have to look at our
patients as individuals and apply that
knowledge so I still think on a
population level it is a disease and
then how we attribute it to each patient
and how we help each patient navigate
their condition that's going to be
different and that's okay I would rather
be skinny than fat I think there's a lot
of different struggles when it comes to
being a bit bigger I have a sister she's
400 lb and she struggles a lot she has
lymphadema and the to shower is really
really hard so I do think for like an
overall happy life and like zero
struggle I think I'd rather be skinny I
think what we're pointing out here is
something that I frequently talk about
this channel when people in the past
have accused me of being fat phobic
where I'm aiming to not just prolong my
patients life and decrease their risk of
disease but also improve their quality
of life and that's exactly what she's
talking about here being able to be
independent being able to wash yourself
have less strain on your knees on your
hips developing arthritis early which
means that you can't exercise or move up
and down on stairs in your home and I
think saying I would rather be skinny
than fat doesn't mean necessarily that
you hate yourself if you are in fact
plus- siiz if you're seeking to improve
because you're constantly unhappy with
yourself that might be an unhealthy
coping mechanism but if you're seeking
to improve cuz you're seeking growth and
you see it from a positive aspect rather
than a hate aspect then that could be a
very healthy mechanism I had the most
body insecurities when I was small and
rather than trying to control my body to
avoid that negative attention I would
prefer to address the situation as a
society we aren't feeling like I have to
be a certain way that's normal in order
to be treated like a human being and
respected one of the the big takeaways
from her sentence there is that she
talks about how we need to address this
from a societal perspective that's
absolutely true with the way our current
Society is fed with the food products
that are allowed in our system the ultr
processed foods being more readily
available and cheaper than true whole
food healthy products food deserts areas
where there's not enough access to good
quality foods all of those things matter
now the medical perspective has probably
gotten more of a highlight with
medications like OIC and The glp1
Agonist because that is more of a
financial incentivized way of treating
our obesity epidemic it's much better to
create a medication that you can make
billions of dollars on than it is to
create a sustainable change in our
society that will lead to people losing
weight I don't think skinny always
equates to being healthy I don't know
where I'd want to lean at a appropriate
weight level but I think it's important
to understand for some skinny people
we're not living a great life by any
means and sometimes I feel like that's
always kind of Lost in Translation when
they see someone who's really skinny
well I think that goes to show that no
matter what a person looks like you
can't know what they're going through
this is why as a doctor you have to walk
into a room with a blank slate and not
judge people but at the same time be
able to stereotype certain conditions
in the sense of okay you're having
symptom X Y and Z that frequently
stereotypically happens in condition X
so I'm going to try and rule out
condition X so there is some
stereotyping you're doing in order to
come to a diagnosis but then you don't
want to stereotype the person's Behavior
or their appearance and it's very
important to distinguish between
positive stereotyping in healthcare and
negative stereotyping in healthare both
truly exist America has an obesity
problem I think we have a problem with
how to treat obesity I think we have a
problem with how to make it so that it
is not an epidemic this is a systemic
thing that we are in a society and in an
environment that breeds this and we are
doing it to ourselves we are doing it to
our children and our corporations and
our Industries are doing it to us and
they aren't having to take
responsibility this is true the one
thing that I have to point out is that
this is a worldwide problem as we have
more access to food and food is driving
our happiness and we are becoming more
disconnected and More Lonely we seek
food for comfort and while companies
certainly bear some share of the
responsibility for making sure that
they're not contributing to this problem
which they absolutely are ultimately
it's not as simple as saying hey company
don't sell this product it's easier said
than done to villainize a corporation
and then say at the same time but it
should be fair how do we make that fair
that villainization and they're
encouraging it with media and the
mukbangs I was literally going to bring
that up you the mukb and like all those
videos that just come up to Trends not
only the mukbangs but also like lizo and
other big like media I don't think I
agree with that uh because lizo has been
an example of not that we're celebrating
that she has excess weight we're
celebrating the fact that she's not
allowing people who are being negative
to her about her weight and still
succeeding so we're celebrating her
success not the fact that she's
potentially carrying excess weight she's
dressing extremely scantily clad and
then saying if you don't think that it's
normal for a morbidly obese person to be
wearing a g- string in the middle of
public then you're the problem and
they're trying to normalize Society to
this obese culture which is extremely
unhealthy you do need to normalize it to
some degree and I'll explain why we're
here we're not going back and there's a
significant population in the United
States that does fall under the umbrella
of obesity you can't neglect that
population you can't be destructive to
them and say that anyone who is
overweight should not be showing their
bodies should be hiding themselves
because they're not a good example Ro
model that is ineffective and that is
what fat shaming is so instead we need
to celebrate people for who they are
celebrate people for the actions they
take if they serve as good Role Models
celebrate those people as humans and
respect them as humans and at the same
time we can give them access to
potentially lose weight to make other
changes in their lives that have nothing
to do with weight that can make them
healthier but at the end of the day like
you can't judge someone for choosing to
wear a certain thing because you don't
Vibe with one part of their health
Journey again it's one part of their
health Journey what is an obese culture
a culture which like normalizes OB I
haven't even heard that well obesity is
already normal so it's I don't think it
should be normalized the problem is when
she says it shouldn't be normalized what
you're doing is fat shaming you're
telling people that they're abnormal no
matter if you have good intentions with
that statement because you want people
to be healthier let's say that's not a
valuable thing to say to the general
public the way it needs to be done is
with them coming to a conclusion of I
need to be healthier I choose to be
healthier and then Society the medical
industry helping them reach their goals
but to say that they're not normal
you're not going to make positive change
by doing that diet culture has positive
effects diet culture is about turning
the word diet from uh your your overall
eating into um an activity that takes
place over a period of time uh a diet it
should not be something you do from
January until May of next year yeah what
you eat should be part of your lifestyle
as opposed to like the activity you're
doing right now I have to point out here
the research that we have of carrying
excess weight specifically excess fat
shows that it it shortens life it
increases risk of disease the disease is
not just limited to our heart and our
brains ffect all our organs our
performance our quality of life our
chances for Independence as we age even
our fertility cancer risk all of those
things so we absolutely need to approach
this from a societal level a medical
level all of the above it's not a
one-sized fits-all answer and whether or
not obesity is a choice is not as simple
as saying yes and no it needs to be
individualized to the person sitting in
front of you and the strategies to help
that person are going to be different
than the strategies going to be help
another person or the strategies that we
discuss on a systemic level and I think
all of those things need to be taken
into consideration we shouldn't just
seek systemic change and forget about
the medical perspective we need to do
both we shouldn't just focus on the
populationbased changes and forget about
the individual strategies we need to be
able to do both that's why at the end of
the day having a good long-term
relationship with a primary care doctor
will go a long way to improving Health
outcomes and I think that's the biggest
takeaway and the idea that the medical
society is fraught with bias and all
that is true and that carrying excess
weight is still unhealthy is also true
and we need to be able to accept both of
those as realities and make change as we
see fit let's watch a middle ground on
vaccines and hear my thoughts on that
click here check it out and as always
stay healthy and happy happy and healthy
but that both
work